[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis très content chantilly pendant
que deux pièces qui se passe
t il quand ça va pas très bien mais pas
dans des tubes de voix c'est qu'on les
voit les images après qu'on ait moi oui
bah oui parce que ça va se corser
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de dossiers
comme chaque jour je regarde ce qui se
passe pendant les pubs pendant les
magnétos et on commence tout de suite là
peut-être que vous est il à peu près 20
heures 15 entre 10 et 12 et en
pantoufles en peignoir de votre canapé
vous allez assister un concours
d'imitation très gênant dans 50 secondes
inside man avec cyril qui tente de faire
castaldi j'entends qu'ils tentent de
faire perler kof les loups c'est sa
carte chez gowlings side tu peux un peu
plus
salut à tous et bienvenue dans sa
catégorie side tpp est encore tout de
suite avec guillaume genthod qui se
prend pour nicolas canteloup compte nous
servent vous insulter tous les français
ses navires s'est on te télévision jours
à une nation
ligue des champions ça chaque sénateur
vous connaissez le rail fruits et
légumes par jour les loups à manger bien
sûr dire que cette balade maintien tant
qu attendait c'est vrai quelle triste
nest alain fréhaut pas
beaucoup le scier tel film spider voici
tout de suite delphine wespiser c'est
incroyable on a chéri tout va bien je me
sens bien
et puisse coupe matthieu delormeau va
prendre une nouvelle qui va bouleverser
sa vie ou pas au bureau
[Musique]
moi je sens les cas mam
we meet you castaldi comme celle du site
comme si ne pas parier sur robin du tout
étonnant que tunis a géré les bêtes pour
le coup on le coude en place dans cette
bd
et qui est premier sur le rap autour la
table certainement pas matthieu
delormeau
caris
à dubaï où la doxa l'alliance
dauphiné avec un petit conseil si vous
voulez confier un secret cyril ne le
faites surtout pas
ça va mon franck tout va bien dans ta
vie
bien y entrer jusque génie écoute ça va
raconter manière vous étiez le
célibataire le plus convoité de paris et
de francis batta
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attendez pas à sa réponse a lui aussi un
de
mes meilleurs amis vous le savez pas
quoi vous dire qu'ils m'avaient quelque
chose qui m'a blessé oui c'est quoi
c'est vrai en plus pendant l'émission on
discute on s'entend bien que s'achevant
chamaillent et il me follow sur un star
et elle rentre chez moi il m'a vu une
photo
c'est juste c'est un ami il est lucide
dirigeants qu'ils doivent faire j'ai
juste demandé de ne pas avoir de
mauvaises fréquentations ça ça m'a vexé
comme moi que je peux raconter
l'histoire avec fait bien sûr il a
insisté très très lourdement pendant des
heures et des heures en le demandant que
qu'il le flou sur un stade donc il l'a
fait tout en lui disant qu'il allait
quand même le non non c'est pas vrai et
si et hakim hamidi qui était là lui a
dit je te confirme quand il va rentrer
et vattenfall ou alors il le savait on
part en week end la semaine prochaine
bompard ou mais dites moi j'attendais
avec voilà si vous voulez vous joindre à
nous j'aurais mais voilà enfin une
promesse si vous voulez vous joindre à
nous et on est complet
on est que tous les deux on a besoin de
se retrouvent d'henri ramène moi on va
rire oui mais pour l'instant décliné de
0,1 on a besoin de se retrouver à vo en
face on bat samba samba ou non et c'est
tout à fait ce qu'on fait on en cherche
un volet d'aidé pour vous d'aller on ne
sait pas encore on a envie de partir
tous les deux trois jours comme ça pour
eux mêmes c'est un peu alors la
recherche comme ça franchement je viens
on va rigoler oui mais bien pour
l'instant oui oui mais c'est moi
c'est bon ça concia les avec vous non
mais pas tous si vous rapproche de poste
du cannet franck toi oui toi oui autant
mais justement on va faire connaissance
ben voilà oui oui
encore par matthieu delormeau c'est quoi
son principal défaut est égoïste et mais
pas que c'est aussi un bâtard
[Rires]
d'immenses et magnéto battant comme ça
dure la culture est ma collection de
choses d'animer des je suis et où
on se re contextualise vendredi soir
après une longue semaine intensive
sorbonne deux heures je cherchais à part
quelques défend de chez moi
et m'ont demandé ce que c'était que
cette histoire de boxe parce qu'il vous
voyez vous l'avez expliqué dans
l'émission
ça ralentit
et sur le rôle ça problème à yves
électro bernard toujours de piment à la
jeunesse la gêne à l'humour et la jeune
et
méconnue coup c'est pas la peine de
faire trop de tuning et concéder moins
de maquillage et oui c'est comme mettre
des mauvaises gens sur une reine qu'est
ce ça américain
102,13 l'histoire
[Musique]
c'est magique lors la bataille
bravo tout cas vous êtes vraiment sympa
mais bon on examine et vous avez dit des
belles choses avaient des casiers tu es
très belle bien sûr la belle qu'elle
s'appelait d'ailleurs pardon mais
aujourd'hui mais on a enlevé les trucs
de clown bassari travers m'étais
beaucoup plus jolie est beaucoup plus
jolie bernard la baisse à rien ça
revient très mode en ce moment oui les
bons points et surtout qui met des
chemises à manches courtes encore en
bâtiment ça avec un tee shirt on
l'essayé sinon
à lui va très bien alors c'est très beau
les chemises à manches courtes mois avec
un t-shirt onctueuse et je vais leur jeu
va en mettre très bon c'est vrai j'aime
bien on a acheté à son bras ne sombrez
pas alors le week-end prochain je
mettrai les chemises à manches courtes à
bras tous les trois ans je paie du mois
courant par un des rétros police à tout
va on va vous chez vous certainement
mais voilà en tout cas s'il vient pas ça
me vexe sera je comprends alors je vais
vous dire je vais en invité deux agents
comment va se marrer nou 2 1 genton
c'est très possible toujours lui changer
un peu oui tu te vois dans un jacuzzi
toikeusse car tu te vois dans un jacuzzi
avec nous avec cyril oui à quelle
horreur
j'aurais l'impression d'être dans ce
temps franchement maintenant s'est
séparé jacuzzi non non mais c'est quoi
la thématique de ce week-end avec toi je
viens
c'est un de mes murs des salles on a
besoin de retrouver et de faire le point
sur nos baptiste cuq est d'accord le
posteur quoi on va travailler c'est une
retraite une sorte de retraite sur notre
vie oui c'est ça sur le cinéma vous
n'êtes pas du tout sur la zone de
travail vient de sueur compagnie des
êtres humains voilà on sait jamais
peut-être qu'on va écrire ken pas
l'action producteurs du tout voilà en
tout cas je sais écrire j'ai des idées
enfin oui je serai pas de trop en faire
quelques comment un podcast un podcast
c'est quoi non c'est quoi ton avenir
alors ma part oui de l'animosité
[Rires]
commence à me prendre de quoi non
opérées sur chérie fm ah oui donc
vraiment macquarie a terminé on essaie
vraiment de m'anéantir total cela
commence mal géré à musique en train de
mettre une des plus grandes radios non
c'est la radiologie
c'est parti est ce que vous savez qui
avait que des crevards autour de cette
table oui bah oui vous compris non non
il ya quelques semaines accents
guerriers notre assistant plateau et
bien avait proposé une cagnotte litchi
pour
il a récidivé en affirmant et bien qu'il
avait trouvé un petit billet dans les
loges
à votre avis autour de cette action
était de crevards je donne la réponse
c'est oui morgan am
pape attendu
[Musique]
ce sens
entre bar
parisien
il dit
centrale
j'étais numéro
crevard
j'ai donné de l'édition utile mais non
leur écoute peut-être mais dans le doute
si c'est pas moi
la audi a joué à dix et aussi la page
de faire quelque chose c'est qu'on sait
pas on a perdu
la zone
[Applaudissements]
jean sasson la toussaint
vingt six ans si si c'est possible si
tu en es perdu seulement parce que ça
aussi
mais je pense soit dans les loges soit
là où on se change
qui souhaiterait dans la loge de
maquillage
var
c'était bien moi je consulte
oui j'ai perdu un billet de
kouadio la bonne je sais juste dans le
cloud c'est bien sûr lecteurs parce que
moi je suis que je trouvais cette en bas
des escaliers
je te donnerai pas la fin d'émission
nous donner
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'adore mamadou bah là où tu l'as trouvé
justement c'est le principe de base est
que je ne sais pas où tu l'a perdue
c'est au tour le retrouverez tout de
suite bravo et bravo moi alors moi pour
le coup comme des douanes de lyon j'ai
vraiment perdu son
boulot
vous l'aurez perdu aller serrer laborde
repartir c'est j'ai découvert un profil
psychologique très spéciale autour de
cette table un vrai mythomane à votre
avis de qui il s'agit si l'équipe ce
soir je vais à plein temps genton ces
gens dont c'est guillaume genre et on va
non il est pas mythomane je vous laisse
regarder le magnéto et je vous explique
tout aussi réel là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que tout commence donc lundi
dernier lorsque guillaume apprend que
delphine wespiser va passer la semaine à
paris seul tout seul elle est toute la
semaine à paris ouais bah oui roger
votre amoureux mais pas il va venir non
il va pas venir il vient pas de toute la
semaine vous pouvez nous le signer
quoi une prouesse eu lieu dans la
capitale rassurez-vous guillaume gens
pourris sur le dossier
[Musique]
inquiétez pas je circulais sécurité le
temps sécuritaire sécurité c'est vite
dit il sachez que le genton ne renonce
jamais tétreault
regardez bien steven spielberg est entré
dans le cerveau de guillaume genton et
assez plus des films qui se fait mais
des trilogies
cyril c'est une nouvelle race qui sévit
dans tpm p le psychopathe mythomane
[Musique]
je cherche un logement
des gens des excuses bidons 18 les
hôtels sont complets
[Musique]
vient chez toi je vais maintenant si toi
commencé à bosser un vrai malade sur
genton et la principale caractéristique
du psychopathe mythomane cyril c'est
quoi c'est quoi le culot
l'apprendre
alors si tu préfères tu es
alors guillaume genton va t'il autant
personnelle fait au guillaume genton
bâti lors
que c'est guillaume est d'accord avec
moi bien sûr je suis bon pack ou mal
comme ça demain mais
c'est vrai je n'ai pas peur de le dire
de la fille de marcel manhattan ben oui
un message oui c'est lui ça va
[Musique]
c'est équivoque c'est très clair alors
là oui oui c'est bien dormi celui-là il
a bien dormi quoi quant à bien dormir
pour interrogation celui-là il est bien
sûr oui parce que
bien dormi c'est vraiment quand on voit
quelqu'un le matin bien dormi voilà ça
veut dire j'ai pensé à toi c'est énorme
et ça veut dire tu me rendes ça veut
dire ma première pensée du matin et pour
toi
tu as déjà avec quelqu'un qui est déjà
été généreux
vous avez aussi des bien dormi son monde
tu fais quoi j'ai une chroniqueuse
kidman on voyait bien dormi ouais mais
là on va se retrouver
samedi
je me rate sophie davant qui a mis cette
élection c'est tout sauf eric je vais
ritz linka autour de la table 7 chronos
mesut özil ou non si l'on dit ou ici
c'est daniel moreau
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
attendez je vérifie pas ce que c'est
pas vraiment répond non non non je n'ai
pas reçu sa a annoncé que j'ai reçues et
manquaient pas pu dormir un peu ce matin
oui
c'est bien je suis barré traite à dormir
il le nom non je ne peux pas en quoi je
ne peux pas dire éviter dit non j'ai vu
le nom m
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que je balaie sedan
non
seulement c'est le public me le demande
[Applaudissements]